I couldn't have sat down now
I was at my cousin's birthday party
Red Lobster November 9th
at Red Lobster geez I gotta tell you gun
right I find that really hard to believe
[Music]
it's a lot anyone could tell this if you
know about my allergy to all shellfish
just confess conrack I
fast that shellfish is the only thing
that rhymes with tell this
[Applause]
look Rasheed I'm gonna make this really
nice and easy for you I need names and
you're gonna give them to me you'll have
to listen to me you have to listen to me
this is all a huge
palmina Homeland Security's been
monitoring your calls for weeks regime
we got you we know about you and your
friends
we know that you're a terrorist I am a
terrorist
we me and my friends we breed dogs
specifically Terriers we write terrorist
fiction we we spend a good deal of time
discussing possible future terrorist
plots
it's a nice try
really is
come on is that the best you got
no come on I'm listening just tell me
tell me tell me about this imminent
attack
what what
I don't know what are you talking what
am I talking about I don't know huh I
don't know what you're talking about you
don't know I don't know I don't know
June 11th
you spoke of an imminent attack oh oh
yes that was my friend listen his dog
bit him and I told him if you do not
train them another Terrier attack is
imminent
so you lied and you see what happens
come on Regine I like you let's be
friends huh
now you still haven't explained to me
why we found on the search engine of
your computer the words Target
Washington 49 times that that is because
I was in DC for a dog show and I had to
buy a squeezy toy a birthday card and
some deodorant all at an affordable
price all right you can only do that
again yeah okay I see how you want to
play this
this is not a case I'm mistaken identity
rajeed and you know it we've heard the
conversations between you and Jafar were
you discussing your hatred of American
ideals foreign
we got you on tape referring to so far
as one of the Architects
it was seven eleven
[Music]
signs convenience stores
7-Eleven
oh
Wilson 65 dogs just attacked the Capitol
Building were the Terriers
how did you know
Johnny
okay Carter
I can stay here all night
so why don't you and I cut the crap and
you tell me what happened on March 15th
and what's in it for Carter Finley
what's in it for you is I don't send you
back to jail
[Music]
the guy's name is cat branchman I met
him downtown at a club called the clutch
and kitten you may have heard of it it's
down on the corner of hang and Fur
Street cat branchman
so what's a guy like you and a guy named
cat
[Music]
okay I know what you're doing Finley
you're just using what you see in my
poster I'm not detective I'm telling the
truth we'll see how much truth you tell
after a few weeks in solitary fine
detective you've twisted my arm that's
better
the guy's name wasn't cat branchman
it was a Chinese guy named Mr meow
he's the real gang boss
story went he hung guys from trees and
took pictures of them Finley used to run
a club downtown a front of course called
it the Paul and poster Finley ran it
with a guy named Hong in Dar okay
stride us one more time
[Music]
Finley
who do you work for
[Music]
um
coffee Mr Coffee
coop
coffee Coop his name was baldy tall man
coffee Coop now you're just talking
about me Finley I'm gonna give you one
more chance
who is in charge his name was angry man
the warehouse is located in the diploma
for being a detective I want a name
Justin thank you hang true don't say
hang God damn it do not say hang
hang nope hangman Justin cat Finley's
poster do not say poster or cat
poster okay that's it I'm losing my
patience Winslow get this out of
here
all right
[Music]
I'm losing my patience
let's try this one more time
getting too old for it
well played Detective
well played indeed
hey Carter
you hang in there
[Music]
good morning
uh Clive Double Down ruggins
I'm Daniel Tate I am your parole officer
and I just want to help you how the hell
are you supposed to help me man what the
you know about the streets what
would your diplomas on the wall
settle down
I know that
you might not be able to relate to me
but
I think
I know somebody who you can relate to
little homie what
in class
no dog listen hey man I ain't trying to
talk to no puppet man it's not a puppet
it's little homie I would like for you
to talk to him Clive see I used to work
in the juvenile Corrections systems and
I found this method very effective I had
no juvenile man okay he's right does he
look like a kid to you come on he's a
grown ass man see what
look it's very important for your parole
that you talked to a little homie
what's up little homie
what you getting into these days man
what it is what it is you got a job yet
I'm trying man but uh no one will hire
me yeah hey
all that noise man
between you and me man ain't nobody
trying to hide with a record but hey man
what you need to be doing is get back
into some crimes man
what's going on man are you talking to
me yeah well you should be talking to
little homie right yeah talk to me
look at me when I'm talking to you okay
okay okay fine
so you smoking weed
no man no no little homie uh I'm I'm
done with drugs
I got something
look at this
[Music]
smoke this week no no no no no no man
I'm done man you hear me I'm done with
drugs I ain't doing all that I don't
know
little homie seems pretty serious about
that here
look I'm confused man what do you want
me to do here well I want you to clean
up your act but you're not talking to me
right now you're talking to little homie
I smoked this right here
oh God
he's not messing around I think I think
you better do what he says
no homie man just relax man relax a
little homie take it easy I'm gonna
smoke it down
wait wait no no no no no no no no no you
can't fool me
are you trying to trick me man
no no I'm done with the weed
catch
dumbass now your fingerprints is on the
weapon you in this with me now right
okay little homie yeah
huh
well oh oh
you failed the test
I have no choice but to revoke your
parole
may I ain't this about a on your
feet baby boy get him out of here come
on
I can't believe that knee Grumps
actually thought I killed you
I know right
[Music]
first things first I do not care that
you're a multi-platinum selling rapper
gun rack
what I care about is that I 100 percent
know that you murdered Darnell Simmons
so you better start talking
[Music]
yeah what you ain't got enough
okay
you know I'm actually I'm very glad that
you said that
because respectfully
I beg to differ
now yeah I shot him with my knot I shot
him nine times nine pm on the dime and
by the way it was November 9th
[Music]
I got a vivid imagination
I couldn't have shot done now
I was at my cousin's birthday party
Red Lobster November 9th
at Red Lobster geez I gotta tell you gun
right I find that really hard to believe
[Music]
like a monster it's a lot anyone could
tell this if you know about my allergy
to all selfish
just confess conrack I
I fast that shellfish is the only thing
that rhymes with tell this
bars
nouns adjectives
they just happen to be in adult order
but
man got no pearl
Shut Up song now with a long-ass gun and
tossed it into the aquarium
I have no idea what that object is
if I had to identify it I would call it
a gun of the long ass variety some
seaweed in there too look the tattoo I
had to break it to you I ain't killing
on it
struck my chin real slow when I'm lying
and I was laughing super hard and
Darnell was dying the name of the album
is I killed Darnell Simmons
that's a picture of you a picture of you
and behind you
coincidence you're going away for a long
time you understand you're gonna confess
if it's the last thing you'll ever do
you hear me come back
thank you
he's free to go what no no no no we have
everything we need no I was Simon's
girlfriend she just confessed to the
whole thing infidelity crime of passion
let's go Mr rack
[Applause]
[Music]
on his track I got a ride or die I
think you get the gist and when you let
me out I'm gonna blow a little kiss this
is my confession admissible in court I
killed Darnell Simmons for sport
that's right I'm a murderer come get me
come down the hall you can get me okay
okay okay you got me dummy damn
[Music]